you and this sponge are killing me I
[Music]
wanted to see you in the top four side I
know but you know things happen
everything happens for a reason and I'm
just grateful I know it sounds like the
cheesiest corniest example hey I'm just
grateful that I got to be a part of the
experience I was in the in the first
decade of RuPaul's Drag returned I mean
all these other [ __ ] after us but you
know I was in a persnickety drag
especially ten like the culmination of a
combination of all of that so it's I'm
still very happy and excited and
hopefully I get to do an all-stars
moment at some point a let's has a
chance to redeem myself and show Ruth at
peak at wigs are more than what I did
over with them on the show yeah what
brought some hair out tonight hello I'll
give you the brightest pungent star girl
Helene on this look tonight oh you know
obviously this plungers has become one
of the most iconic moments of season ten
we're gonna see the same meeting of this
monstrous so I wanted to do a very
elevated glam and a high cut for a
moment of a sponge dress so this I have
my suds here as some studs in my hair
and the yellow and green and the
crystals on everything and I feel great
where is that scotch-brite endorsement
deal that's hello I have emailed them
they have blocked me but I'm gonna keep
on trying them Beautyblender any anyone
who has a sponge anything combo Nate out
girl we need to do a
a little moment together I'm literally
cleaning the floor with my garment I'm
not joking this one dress was the
greatest season the music video getting
in the pool with the sponge dress how
heavy was that coming out it was like to
Eureka
O'Hara's draped on my body it was so cuz
I have a surprise the pool so hot water
in it but it was so silly and I was like
I wanna do something ridiculous I said
to the director sorry I cou I was like I
want to be ridiculous I want to get in
the water with this sponge rest of these
separate them it was it was so silly
soak it up people love it I hope to see
on all-star spoil me